hurry John Corrales masa live.com
obviously this didn't go the way you
wanted to and it may be very early for
this but can you reflect on this season
this is the season you said you asked
for this is the moment you said you
asked for what are your thoughts right
now in the immediate aftermath just just
a lot of lessons to take from this
season from day one at training camp all
the way till now you know it's just felt
like a rush you know try to enjoy as
many moments as I could you know just it
it really comes down to great team
basketball who's playing better at you
know a certain time of the year and the
connectivity and they're able to respond
and you know they they showed all year
while they were who they were and you
know they were very dominating in this
series after Game one you know they
played hard they they did unbelievable
things with their rotations and you know
Mike put him in some great positions to
be successful as well as guys coming in
off the bench playing well playing
steady you know got us on and George and
you know they're just leading that
second unit and I think Yanis and Chris
did a great job of leading our group as
well as Ebola coming in and filling in
where he could as well I think
collectively as a group they really
outplayed us as a group and I give
credit to them because they they came
after game one game punched in the mouth
and they responded the way a team that
you know deserves to win show it Kerry
Kerry Washington Boston clone two
questions one how disappointing this is
no you know you guys were picked to go
to the finals or you want to do great
things with this team in this
organization and how disappointed are
you in to what we do for the next six
seven weeks before you have a big
decision to make and it's Boston a place
that you would consider coming back I
mean you know true PTO's it's no time to
be disappointed I think that you know
you take your lessons you take your ass
hoping that they handed us and you move
on you know it's a basketball journey
obviously you know you want to keep
but they put a halt today and they
deserve this series they they play like
they wanted it and um and I'm looking
forward to seeing them going an Eastern
Conference Finals and playing their next
opponent you know is a it was it was a
great opponent to prefer for me to play
against for the rest of my career
because I know I won't forget something
like this and you know the the taste of
feeling defeat and you know in this type
of style you know being down one for you
know I haven't felt so you know for me
it's just moving on to the the next
thing and just seeing where where that
ends up Adam Hillman spoke with the
Boston Globe when you kind of look
forward to this summer just in general
what kind of what kind of things are you
looking for I guess in your life and
what kind of things kind of situations
would be a positive situation that you
want to be in when you I'm gonna be
honest which I'm just trying to get back
to Boston first you know safely I get to
see my family do you compress you know
do what human beings do
Kairi Andrew Wagner Forbes sports so
much gets made of Milwaukee's offensive
abilities but what was their defense
like that kind of got different from the
regular season two game one - over the
last few games oh well they kept a body
on me practically the whole game you
know and then they they put us in some
rotations offensively and defensively
did a great job of running their offense
with pace making us think out there and
I think that that's where one of the
important lessons I'm gonna take from
this is just how smart you know our team
has to be in order to be at that next
level and they did it all year I mean
they stayed consistent they stayed
steady they stayed relatively healthy
you know and like I said I give credit
where credit's due Yanis is unbelievable
player he's been doing unbelievable
things this year as well as Chris and
they fell in very well they're they're
great well-run team so I you know I'm
you know I'm glad that we got to feel
this and the eyes of looking at a great
team like that Kyrie Michelle Steele
ESPN you mentioned at the top that you
you took some lessons away from this
play off a series
what were they what what's a lesson that
sticks out to you from this series
the patient's out there on the floor
just to pace and being very
communicative you know those are main
things and I can have a follow up really
quickly
um you know plenty of people here are
speculating about your future and
certainly this summer did uncertainty
all over that way on you and in any way
in this Psalms no